[Música]
El Fuerte terremoto que sacudió a
Turquía y asiria nos Recuerda que estos
países están en una de las regiones con
la más alta sismicidad del mundo allí
los movimientos telúricos son habituales
en directo a América los ponemos en
contexto Turquía está ubicada en la
Península de anatolia esta región del
mundo reposa sobre cuatro placas
tectónicas estamos hablando de la placa
euroasiática la placa de anatolia la
africana y la arábica que viene por este
lado de el país el terremoto que acaba
de registrarse en ese país con magnitud
de 7.8 fue ocasionado por el choque de
tres de estas placas estamos hablando de
la placa arábiga de la africana y de la
anatolia que justamente es la placa más
pequeña y debido a la presión que
recibió por parte de estas dos placas Se
movió hacia el oeste de la Península la
información que suministra el afat que
es la autoridad de gestión y desastres y
emergencias de Turquía por en Turco
indica que el epicentro del primer sismo
de magnitud 7.8 tuvo lugar en pasar sic
en esta zona del país en el sur del país
muy cerca de la frontera con Siria
posteriormente hubo otro temblor de
magnitud 7.6 con Epicentro en el bistán
que es muy cerca a la zona del terremoto
original las regiones afectadas son las
de caramangaras gazan adana adillamán y
aitat en el lado sirio podemos ver acá
en el mapa que la ciudad más afectadas
fueron alepo que ya estaba destruida por
la guerra en la cual ha estado inmerso
este país desde hace más de una década
it hamma y también el puerto del ataque
también otros países vecinos sintieron
con intensidad este sismo justamente
este fuerte sismo hace recordar el
registrado en ese país en 1939 que es el
récord que ha registrado Turquía se
trata de un terremoto de magnitud 7.8
que en su momento 30.000 muertos el
sismo de hoy tiene lugar también en un
momento muy complejo para este país una
economía con una alta inflación afectada
seriamente por la pandemia del Coby 19 y
también por la Guerra de Ucrania es un
país que también está en plena campaña
para la presidencia la reconstrucción
sin duda alguna pasará a ser uno de los
temas principales de la campaña la
rapidez y la respuesta que dé el
gobierno Turco para darle algunos
réditos políticos al actual presidente
erdogan podrían traducirse en votos para
su reelección Turquía también ha
intentado ser un jugador a gran escala a
nivel mundial y eso se ve en la
respuesta que ha habido por parte de
diferentes países cerca de 45 naciones
han enviado ayuda entre ellos Estados
Unidos la Unión Europea china Rusia y
también Israel lo que da cuenta de su
buen relacionamiento a nivel global del
otro lado pues está Siria que en medio
de una guerra civil ya desde hace más de
10 años está parcialmente destruido este
país y con serios problemas económicos y
sociales recuerde que usted puede
encontrar más información también en
nuestra página web France 24.com y en
nuestras redes sociales
[Música]